hitting your wife 5,000 rubles beating
your child 7,000 family values priceless
a poster that intends to shock there's a
protest that's increasingly unwelcome in
today's Russia they've been repeatedly
refused permission to hold a
conventional demonstration all that's
left at his activists is individual
picketing within minutes private
security guards are on the scene the
pavement is private property they say
and the activists are forced to move on
by law there must be at least 50 meters
between each protester any less and it's
an illegal demonstration a rule that
keeps many of those who had wanted to
take part away Russia's upper house of
parliament supporters of the amendment
here argued that this is about putting
an end to disproportionate punishment
for so-called minor act of violence and
only for first time offenders they say
existing legislation already provides
women with sufficient protection and
that the problem is far from widespread
but I seek out of the game Civic shows
us every day over 6000 crimes are
committed in Russia it's only a hundred
and thirty five of those take place
within families the family home is much
safer than the world outside the idea
that this problem is growing all that it
poses a threat to Russia is just untrue
it's a myth but did there watching by
troy smith that's a claim activists
anastacio tear over rejects her
organization estimates that some 14,000
women died at the hands of their
partners every year in Russia anastacio
started campaigning for women's rights
after escaping in a beautiful a shin
ship if I tell me I was this he grabbed
me by the hair like this he got hold of
my trousers there were a few steps where
we were maybe 10 he pushed me down
headfirst to Pollock what in LA wooden
again I fell and landed at the feet of a
young man who was walking up towards us
he bent down to help me my partner said
don't touch her she's drunk I wasn't I
don't even like drinking but even if I
had been
why shouldn't he have helped me he took
his hand away and walked off on a rocket
arrow pretending it was a really
powerful desh it didn't occur to her to
go to the police for help back then the
penalty is now set to be abolished
weren't even on the statutes need for
new no one goes to the police the first
time it happens if a woman goes to the
police it means she's been through real
agony it means the violence has gone on
for days and weeks maybe a leading
indicator anastacio was due to speak at
the council protest she says she's
determined to carry on fighting to be
heard irrespective of whether President
Vladimir Putin signs these amendments
into law or not